good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is take command over to you Tony Robbins
[Music]
what makes you a leader is your ability
to make a decision who's with me on this
right and anybody can make the easy
decision right so what makes you a
leader is you can make the tough
decisions and what makes you a leader is
you make the decision what makes you
great leaders you know I may be wrong
but I'll have to wait till everything's
resolved nothing's gonna get resolved so
I'm gonna make a decision if I make a
decision and it's wrong I'll find out
quicker than if I sit on the fence while
my life goes by I remember I I've showed
this with maybe a few of you before but
years and years ago when we had the big
Gulf War generals you know Norman
Schwarzkopf some friend of mine and
passed away three years ago and I used
to bring him in to talk about leadership
and one of the first times I ever asked
him I said how do you define leadership
you know how do you know what a person
is really leader and he said well they
can make decisions he said I can
remember when I was he was an assistant
to a to a general and I forgot what the
exact position is but he said he was
responsible for reading all the briefs
and this generals highest generals in
the Army and it was a decision that need
to be made and had to deal with ten
years of going back and forth with the
Pentagon trying to figure out well if
they're gonna make a go one direction or
another was a gigantic decision that was
gonna affect the way the army was
structured how money was gonna be
divided what resources are gonna go
where and he said they brought in this
group of twenty people in and they had
this two-hour meeting and everybody got
up and pitched their side of what they
thought was right and at the end when it
was completely done the general said as
everyone said their piece he said yes he
said do this it was plan a and a plan B
whatever it was out of the three choices
the head and everybody said okay usually
okay generals saluted him and ran off to
go implement this thing and and swartz
cop said he was freaking out because he
knew there's no way that general could
have read everything even he'd read
and this was such a complex piece and
there was only two hours and everybody
gave their best but my god there's so
many things to consider and so he
finally he got up enough courage he said
to go the general said general salute
permission to speak freely
he said he's speak freely he said
general there is so much information
here and there's so much here no one's
can really gonna know for sure how the
how could you just make that decision
like that
he said because someone had to make it
he said because it's been going around
for 10 years back and forth and no one
being able to make a decision he said
what if you're wrong he said if I'm
wrong we'll find out quicker if I'm
right the job will be done next question
right it's like when you're put in
charge take command I love this message
and what I would add to it is it's not
just when you're in charge you take
command but to always be looking for
opportunities to take your mind it's an
essential skill to learn as an
entrepreneur how to be a leader and
you're not just given leadership
opportunities a lot a lot of times you
have to step up and take command where
you see a void now that doesn't mean
that everybody should always try to be
taking command right if everybody's
trying to be a commander and there's
nobody else to actually do the work
that's a problem but when you see a void
when you see that there's a vacuum when
you see that there's this hole where
you're walking in circles and you're
going around and the decision needs to
be made and nobody wants to make that
decision that's we need to step up and
do it even if somebody else may have
been appointed in charge I think of a
story here at TDS where Alex who helps
me run the school was downstairs and two
guys started fighting it broke out into
some fight don't know what the cause was
and as a security guard right next to
them and you didn't do anything he's
just kind of watching along like that
guys supposed to be the guy in charge
right like you're in charge of security
you're supposed to keep the place safe
break up fights put it in yours just
watching and so Alex and seeing that
decided to step in and break the two
guys up and stop the fight and so if you
see conflict if you see inaction if you
get frustrated with something even if
there is somebody else in charge you're
supposed to be in charge and they're not
doing it I encourage you to step up and
take command do the right thing where
most people will do is
they'll go home and complain right or
complaining their friends oh there was
this big fight and the security guard
did nothing you know I can't believe
that guy didn't do anything and you put
a lot of blame and responsibility on him
well where were you like what did you do
that make the situation better instead
of complaining out reliefs look inwardly
instead of complaining that nothing
happens at your company or with your
boss or with your customers instead of
complaining them blaming them for not
taking enough action look inward solve
the problem and being the leader and
taking command often sucks because maybe
you make the wrong call because you're
making a decisions based off incomplete
information because if something goes
wrong you're the one who made that call
and we're so afraid of getting the the
failure happened and being placed on us
instead of also looking at hey what if
what if this thing actually turns out
for the positive we don't want to risk
making a mistake in front of other
people so we don't do anything we're so
afraid of making the wrong call in front
of other people and so we make zero call
but that's the point of a leader you
make the best decision that you can with
the information that you have and you
take some action and so I would
encourage you the next time you feel
frustrated next time you feel upset
angry things are not happening as I
showed things you're taking too long
things are going around in circles you
see of a vacuum you see a void of
leadership in your own business or in a
group that you're in or on the street or
with your friends you see a void of
leadership even though it's not your
responsibility even though you haven't
been appointed as the one in charge to
commit solve the problem make it right
stop complaining and do something about
so the question today today is I'm
curious when was the last time you took
command in a situation you weren't
liking how things are going and you said
this is what we're gonna do really
curious to find out leave it down in the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Vicky shim Vicky
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book your one word it really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read thank you guys
again for watching I hope you have an
amazing day I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
I spray so give me go
and I I mean personally I always try to
listen because I might be not and maybe
I'm not getting something I always try
and take everybody's because it's
important to listen to everyone as many
people as you can and get their input
but then finally you have to make your
own decision about what you're gonna do
and that's it that's what you feel and
that's it and that that's the most
important thing I think the most
important thing because that's where the
uniqueness comes in because it's you
you've done it it's your thing it's not
anybody else's it's your choice one
other thing I learned particularly in
Japan that from time to time making
quick decision it's gonna hurt the
execution of the decision because I
think what do you want when you make a
decision what you want you want to
transform reality you don't want to make
a decision for the sake of making a
decision you make a decision because you
want something to change so your goal is
the thing changed that should go so now
the question is when should you make the
decision in order to make sure that this
thing has changed in the fastest period
of time so from time to time you have to
wait to make the decision because you're
preparing people to execute from time to
time you need to make the decision very
early from time to time a little bit
late but when I say this is eveness mean
capacity to take the decision at the
appropriate time because at the end of
the day what you need is reality changes
that's that's your goal if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details